so captain
i have some news
what happened well remember when you
told me not to burn down the precinct
you burned down the precinct no i had
the fire put out almost immediately this
is a success story tell me exactly what
happened now then blocking the caboodle
the cabo dale will be placed in the
center of the bullpen right and what is
the name of the store at the mall that
sells the sticky pastries you mean the
siney bone yeah that was a thanks
continue
sometimes i can't tell my twin baby
girls apart
so i call them both booboo
wow
so he has no filter whatsoever none
i'm gonna take you home now sarge hey
what do you think of captain holt
oh he needs to smoke some weeds yes
thank you dr penis off
thanks for getting there so fast today
sir were you able to still do your
interview he did not however i did so
the real question is what are police i'm
sorry who are you again they said
they've never had more viewer complaints
controversial and loving it
huh
okay see the cut is a little sloppy i
want you to cut it straight across no
big deal
again
yep sloppy don't overthink it
again
now you're not thinking enough
again
still sloppy again
again you know what why don't we try
this why don't you just take that knife
put it to my throat and finish the job
do i look like jake to you do i look
like jake to you no not at all then why
are you trying to screw me
just eating butter like a popsicle huh
boyle yeah i know i'm spoiling myself we
are headed to the east gate we're doing
great i think this is working i can do
this here we go i'm doing it you're
looking away no i'm not stop moving away
not don't look away but i see leaves no
better loved playing in leaves doesn't
matter what kind oak maple elem wait
i hate to cut you off but look what i
found security camera better love
security cameras how is that possible
there's something i'd like to show you
captain
terry
crushed
it it works
i've never been more proud of you for
anything in your life i mean i've solved
a lot of cases for you and yet crime is
continued and captain banned headphones
from the office due to the gina incident
[Music]
what is this glutinous monstrosity
before me the sugar in this is quite
sweet
that's your hult impression i can hear
him doing that looks like a sticky
pillow i don't care for it classical
music
what's going on here what are you doing
captain hey nothing just
eating some marshmallows care for one
marshmallow
i knew it detective hitchcock is set to
testify in court this afternoon it's an
important case and i'd rather not get
another call from the d.a saying he
showed up quote covered in condiments
unquote so you want me to keep hitchcock
from spilling on himself for the rest of
the day we both know that's impossible
i'm counting on i won't do it there's
nobody else i trust what you're asking
is insane i'm not asking it's a suicide
mission then prepare for death you've
lost your mind this is a direct order
detective get in line hey
you guys startled hitchcock he spilled
two full jars of spaghetti sauce on
himself
thanks a lot fellas oh yeah i'm feeling
it now rosa at this time tomorrow we're
gonna know exactly what our killer looks
like we have no idea what our killer
looks like well that's not totally true
we now know that the killer might look
like seth meyer's winona ryder or bilbo
baggins i overheard you mention a bill
beaubaggins should we bring him in well
as much as i would love to meet him he
is not a suspect trust me i'm sort of a
natural mother yeah natural mother
how long have you been there oh man i
have no idea
we're sorry we doubted you sir you
really saved our butts i can't take
credit for that
gina linetti is the real hero here but
isn't gina linetti more of a state of
mind like in a way we were all gina
linetti today
gina let's take this gina to the
hospital
pizzazz is who i am would you tell the
sky to stop being so blue yes i wish it
were tan what it's my favorite color
it's no nonsense
anyway we should motor jake and i are
sticking out a bar called the thirsty ox
loud crime a lot of danger a lot of down
time for inside jokes would you like
some milk
man would you like some milk the kind
because you look like your dog
milk please what's it from it's funny he
remembers it's funny okay very
funny the full bullpen i've been on the
phone for six hours and i just want to
cancel an account
yes you've mentioned the bundles and i
don't want home phone service
no do not transfer me roderick no no no
rodrigo
i swear ma i don't know what this is
about why won't you ever believe me
cause i raised a liar oh you lie shut up
mom hey he'll talk to ma like that don't
you tell me what to do louie excuse me
not the rules
my wife was murdered by a man in a
yellow sweater
it's the one case i can't solve
i am so sorry we yell at you but we will
take those sundays to go and i don't
care if you don't have a lid
y'all make a lid i've crafted an
intricate personal high-five with
everyone in this office except you what
but you hate high-fives yes every minute
of it was hell but it'll be worse for
you squad dismissed
good-bye diaz
[Music]
salute into a fanny wagon goodbye boyle
the snake charmer goodbye jeffers
that's the butt bump goodbye santiago
double fist bump reverse explosion into
a pete townsend strum
all right that was terrible but it's
over now and i made it through goodbye
leonard from xerox what
no no
the copy guy trudy did seem very nice
when i met her are you trying to get
your freak on with my sister what no i
see you looking at triti judy's booty i
am not looking at trudy judy's booty oh
you don't think she's a cutie don't be
snooty she's a beauty but i'm on duty
and you're married yeah but that doesn't
rhyme
stop
you're drinking too much
whoa what's going on charles why are you
talking so slow i'm not i'm normal
[Music]
oh my god if you're not going so that
means we're going faster are we going
fast can we tell if we're going we're
going fast at all in any way whatsoever
i feel like we're going slow in every
way whatsoever captain not even great
excellent amazing i feel better than
i've ever found any moment in my entire
life so we're all fine yep yep yep yep
yep yep yep yep yep yep yep
once is dead bagel bagel
bagel come with me
amy to the dumpster me and amy going
diving in the dumpster there's a
confused old woman here who wants to
talk to a detective
oh come on another drill hello my name
is adelaide i like to report a crime so
we're just doing one of these every day
oh you got it
i know you got it
i want my money
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
what is this music
oh this is from my country near
krakagovia do you like it i weirdly do
[Music]
foreign
you